>> So, here's the quiz. You see on
the screen this sort of unexplained two little squiggles
with a bunch of numbers in front, on top of them or under them or near them?
>> Yeah I, I assume that's a river and on one bank it's the
land of the plus ones and the other bank has been infilitrated by plus twos.
>> That's not what I intended at all but I actually like that enough that I'm
going to pretend, that that's what I intended. So
these work out to be sequences of states.
>> Oh, I see now.
>> Okay,
and rewards that you receive. No, no, no, it's
a riverbank and on one side of the bank, as
you walk along it, you get a bunch of plus
ones. On the other side you get a bunch of
plus ones and some plus twos. And this just
goes on forever, okay? And, I'm not going to tell you
what all the rewards are after that except that they,
they look similar to the rewards that you see here.
>> Okay.
>> Plus ones and plus twos, okay? And let's
say the top, the top one, in fact, nothing
but plus ones. And the bottom ones are some
plus ones with maybe some plus twos sprinkled in and
out, but those are really the only options. Okay?
>> Yeah.
>> Here's my question to you. So, would you
rather be on the top side of the river
bank, or the bottom side of the river bank?
Okay? You think you know the answer already, don't you.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, cool. Well then, let's, let's give our listeners
a, a chance to come up with the right answer.